exactly where's that i don't think you
wouldn't want to walk like that
on that side of the area there's benji
yes everybody knows benji
not really a good scene back there
everywhere you go you got a bridge at
the end of the day all right
salute to you a thousand times this is
your home okay it's been really bad
yeah just be careful man so we got a
pork taco
[Music]
you see my here
hello from new york city this is such a
massive
place with so many different types of
neighborhoods and today we're going to
go into the most dangerous neighborhood
of the city
the south bronx
[Music]
really really really really
149th and third
don't know the name of this hood at
south bronx
we're gonna go from here down to
mott haven so we're gonna cruise around
walk around this neighborhood check out
what's going on and then
mott haven should be interesting
wait where you from dude i was born in
vermont
i lived in ukraine the last four years
california my adult life i just came
back to the states
wow yeah you just i just came back
what's going on there's nothing nothing
there's one word
worse than a year ago yeah well not that
bad
you always be aware look around yeah the
summertime in the summer time
on this block is at least like two three
fights a day
how about the white guy okay yeah you
see no problem
okay cool but walking around like that
yeah i don't know thanks brother i don't
think you wouldn't want to walk like
that
on that side
bit edgier than i thought it would be to
be honest
got some fruit going on here cookies
department store
of course at mcdonald's
you know what right now in new york
no music in the city at least that's
what i've been told so far in manhattan
nothing no street performances and
that's what that's what makes the city
so amazing
is all that live music and energy i'll
tell you what i feel a lot of energy
right now
definitely a different environment than
i've ever
ever been in oh beautiful church there
what church is that bro you know
little reggae that's nice nice vibe
cuts the edge
where's the good food brother see what
lola's is that yeah
go to two blocks there you're gonna see
a nice big restaurant two blocks down
one forty two they're not the lola's
gonna 148 you're gonna see a nice
restaurant what's it called
i've got neighborhood restaurant but
it's nice it's nice
what's your name peter george all right
george what's up
so uh let's go see what the restaurant
scene is like here
[Music]
home cooked chicken what's the name of
this place
fresh kitchen that's what i got out of
that uh
okay full transparency guys the
neighborhood is uh
pretty intense out there oh there we go
it's good chicken
neighborhood's pretty intense i sort of
have to
fuel up and figure out my next steps
this one guy warned me it's
it's gone downhill quite a bit
so uh the goal is
meet some cool people learn about the
[Music]
neighborhood
the bronx is very famous for a few
things
i'd say the number one thing would be
hip-hop rap music
and then also graffiti
i don't know if it started here but it's
uh it's very famous for its graffiti
so new york right now beginning of
october
2020 very interesting place
just a kid very interesting place uh
manhattan seems
pretty quiet i mean there's still life
but
compared to what it's normally like
super quiet
crime across the city
one of the stats i read said homicides
are up 70
this year versus last year
so there's there's a little more edge we
have the pandemic
we have protests a political election
coming
so there is a palpable tension
but then it's also normal life at the
same time
all right what do you got in here
[Music]
do you have like 15 batteries or
whatever
[Music]
here we go
i just walked past quite an interesting
drug scene over there
uh 20 guys shooting on heroin
you said heroin is the big thing here
[Music]
white black hispanic everyone was in on
it just right off the street so he said
the heroine is coming super strong no
more
no longer is it the uh crack but the
heroin and i think there's a lot of it
going on down there
and you can't really put the camera on
heroin
addicts i mean you can i guess but they
look really paranoid obviously because
they think uh
they're a police or something just past
that drug scene is allstate insurance
my wellness solutions safe med
so i'm going east here on 149th and is
turning more
latin feeling the music the people
and that's what new york is you just go
through these streets
and the ethnicities change a lot of
times
all right so i just went into this cell
phone shop met this pakistani guy who's
been here for three years in the bronx
what were you saying bro ron the father
of liar
the bronx is the father of liari
and liari is the um the hardcore
neighborhood
in karachi where there are actually a
lot of rappers and a lot of boxers right
a lot of boxers there
i made a video there and they already
loved it
get my wife one
yes get your white one get my wife one
this is styling it's comfortable too
everyone why don't you guys have one i
wake
up you got to represent the bronx
exactly where's that's what i'm doing
yeah yeah yeah yeah you got time for
today
i hear you what's going on with the
corona here right now
um what's going on
is it going up or going down well not
here
going down going up
going up brooklyn's growing up because
they didn't pay attention the first time
they don't pay attention all right
well you know the duke got their own
doors so
they're not wearing masks they still
ain't weird
and they've got one city they got one
town in brooklyn and there was something
with the
middlesex or something yeah that [ __ ] is
37 percent now
[Music]
oh okay
[Applause]
do you need an appointment or no um just
come in with the id
okay now heading south to mott haven
i believe it's 138th and that's another
busy street
the bronx is a large area it's uh what
is it 42 square
miles so this is the south bronx they're
all different parts of the bronx they're
really nice expensive neighborhoods
there
are more concentrated neighborhoods like
this
a little bit of everything the
population in the bronx overall is 1.4
million people
if it was its own city i forget what it
would be but it's
uh it's got the third highest population
density
in the states i think would be like the
eighth biggest city in america
you see the bars on the windows
obviously showing it's not the safest
neighborhood
but it's got some charm over here garden
areas
things seem to be a little bit better
taken care of
over here vines up the side of the
building
yeah they would barely abuse animals
well done okay
so they're the rescue dogs yes i have to
be nine years
okay they were barely abused they were
beaten they were starving to death
um and
they cut his testicles off the guy who
owned them and left them to dine a
rooftop
in brooklyn there's benji yes everybody
knows benji and i and jesus
[Applause]
it just got nice like right around this
area yeah
under the bridge too she don't bite
really she's like
yeah she's a snapper he's like he's my
wife
they're husband and wife they've been
together since they were babies
oh
she's upstairs i'm about to go get her
now good good seeing you honey you too
so you live you've lived in the
neighborhood a long time no i'm only
here 10 years
ah people cool here everyone gets along
i have no problem with nobody i'm the
only white person in my group
all the jews are building uh buying
everything and building it up
here yeah see this was all jews at one
time it was before
yeah yeah and then you know it had
things go by you know time goes by
yeah and then when i moved here 10 years
ago it was still just this night
i never had a problem with nobody i mind
my business you know
yeah i don't want to get involved with
nobody [ __ ] i don't know nobody's [ __ ]
and oh what's he selling always
somebody's always telling something
i saw a bunch of guys shooting up heroin
up there yeah they do that
down here is nicer yeah they they they
shoot up and in my building chill
they'll be in the elevator smoking crack
i don't understand that
how you open the elevator doing this
smoking crack in there they should get
their ass kicked
down the throat you'll slam it down
their throat yeah because the stem
or the glass whatever they call the pipe
because like i said there's children in
the building how are you going to do
that you live here why don't you do it
in your house
that's your [ __ ] do it in your house
don't do it in the elevator where people
got to see you
yeah yeah
they're so cute okay and then two down
and then the other guy is spanish the
puerto rican man owns three of them
he owns three of them because back in
the days they paid thirty five thousand
dollars for now they're worth over a
million dollars
seriously each one of these over a
million yep yep
they're beautiful take care bye-bye
yeah it looks like we're near a police
station
must be over there that looks vacant up
there look at that one
where is it right there yeah that's
faking and these are the projects
and she said these i don't know i was
the first person i've talked about
she said these some of these apartments
can go up to like fifteen hundred
dollars a pop
but they get free free electricity
what's up guys
hey how's it how's the neighborhood
lately uh
where specifically the whole freaking
like one 149
[ __ ] disaster this whole [ __ ]
disaster yeah should i i was recording
should i shut this up no absolutely not
okay it's been really bad this whole pre
precinct is a [ __ ] show yeah just be
careful man
you moving in are you living here no i'm
just walking through yeah it's it's a
lot it's
super high in crime lately man it's been
like that since what
probably around the corona when they
started it got really bad moving
you know just what about down here 138th
nothing worse than it's been right my
haven
it's better there than over there right
149. well
one four are you talking about the hub
area yeah where the metro comes out yeah
the subway comes out yeah the k2 and a
lot of drug activity yeah they they were
there was like 20 guys just sitting
shooting up on the sidewalks that's all
the way up 149 i mean
i don't know how far you walked on your
recording if you yeah yeah i walked up
there and all the way down
yeah it's kind of live here no if you
look you've talked with the drugs and
you know that
yeah the dope head and k2 it's all the
way up 149 it looks like
it feels like it's been getting worse
around the globe yeah you know guys i've
been out of the country four years i
just got a month ago i did quarantine
all that [ __ ] but um
thank you it's weird yeah you're you're
retreating
they go to uh
you could do that yeah but that's that's
hardcore
yeah i would just stick over here stick
over here and back up and down 149 if
you want or maybe walk through
like patterson all right so
hey it actually looks nice though it's a
good looking area yeah
it does it's a lot nice too until you
touch it
there's a lot of small pockets all right
guys
thank you you're you're italian though
originally right
you look like my father yes
a little bit of a different vibe more
space on the sidewalks not as many
people still lively
this is the traffic that doesn't seem to
be happening in
manhattan right now
quite a vibrant neighborhood
old woman buying ice cream
a little history for you so the bronx is
named after
jonas bronx he uh he was part of the new
netherlands colony swedish explorer
bought the land from the native
americans they tried to grow things they
didn't grow so well
that's how it started off then it was uh
it was irish americans it was german
americans it was italian americans
then around the 40s a lot of caribbean
nations came a lot of puerto ricans came
in
and shortly after a lot of african
americans came into
these neighborhoods so the face has
changed dramatically
in quite a short amount of time
and they got great mexican food i always
find the food scenes quite awkward
eating in front of a camera people seem
to love it so we got a pork taco here
tomato cilantro lettuce
very nice very nice that's about as good
as i am with
food shots i don't know what to do say
it's good have you ever seen a food show
where they say the food is terrible
[Music]
six dollars for a drink and a monster
taco
this place is epic
which is gracious what's the name of
your restaurant santa clarita restaurant
santa clarita restaurant okay
very good mexican food thank you yeah
that place rocks
where'd my man go he took off went he
was like
he went inside okay i didn't have the
power button on when he was talking to
me
oh well what are you reading um
cool do you like raven do you like ray
bradbury
yeah he's good huh yeah i'm science
fiction in holland that's what i read
you're living in a different world yeah
yeah escapism yes
take care guys all right bye-bye
all right sometimes that happens guys
we're
i don't hit the record button right but
anyways
really cool guy telling some facts about
the neighborhood this is a landmark
neighborhood with these brownstones
so you have really interesting
architecture cool doorways
ornate windowsills
some nice color in here this one needs
to be
redone obviously but look at the top
there
that's stunning
you guys did this all yourself yes
that's cool
you take halloween seriously all the way
chris we do that every time for the kids
do you have trick or treaters here um
beautiful
yeah cool i like your style
thank you take care god a lot of cool
people there was another guy back there
uh he was with his girlfriend and
another guy and they were super cool
and awesome they gave me their number
to take me to uh where grand master
flash
grew up and also the the origin of hip
hop
but they didn't want to be on camera but
i'm getting a lot of good
good vibes i mean there is a heaviness
at south bronx
but everyone i've talked to has been
pretty cool so far
hello how are you doing
like that don't be shy
okay watch this what is the purpose of
the reason i love the camera
why are you here the message grandmaster
flash
i love you for the whole purpose of
keeping the culture love
i love you for the spirit from within
self and then also to how do you say
getting it expressed through other
individuals
which is another blessing so when i say
express you're going over to other
people
and you're talking about that topic that
of an individual that was a legacy
which is a blessing and you my friend
are you from the south bronx right here
right here
talk to me about it it's so many
different reflections it's it's all
about the individual
about what they want to bring and what
is the offspring and then how they want
to have
mixture inside of it at the end of the
day so it's all about the individual
when he comes to the south bronx
what his mind frame of thinking is he's
channeling different energies
and once they start channeling different
energies now you're making bridge to all
of those things that you came in contact
with
and then they're going to give off a
relationship which is going to be a
reflection and from that reflection we
built
there's a lot of love in the south bronx
you know i'm not going to just say the
south bronx to put myself in one
category okay i'm going to say all
burgers at the end of the day
because my greatest thing was i just
came back from massachusetts
and i would have never thought the love
would be so overwhelming out there the
way it was
it was outstanding and i'm coming from
the bronx
coming from the bronx going away after
massachusetts and receiving the love
that i received hands down ten times
what you put out you get back well i
told you it's the reflection of the
individual at the end of the day what
are you selling here
we got from movies to um oils to
perfumes to headphones
chargers phone cases ladies
anything you guys like you're more than
welcome anytime you got lovely what's
your name brother
my name is sean they call me black the
movie god bless the movie god
y'all got love when you come out here
okay love you for that partner and keep
doing that
um go pro homework and keep not just
experiencing but keep contacting with so
many individuals so
everywhere you go you got a bridge at
the end of the day all right
salute to you a thousand times this is
your home you got love when you come
through okay
i'll see you when you pass again let me
know what's going on from there all
right
have a good day stop by here again
remember
[Music]
and then you get that in the south bronx
kelly's fashion optical another mexican
place
and there's that psycho dude [ __ ] he's
following me
all right let's get into this
see you're making this for the family no
sir looks good
[Music]
bye bye that's where i
that's go they just got a set up there
outside on the sidewalk a grill going
she had all the condiments it looked
like she was actually selling it
wow look at this bike that looks like
something i have no idea what that is
suzuki all modified out
so you see in the bronx a lot of
beautiful detail
like this a lot of history right
another one let's check this one out
across the street
yeah a lot of little cool detail i mean
it's gritty it's not let's not play
pretend
it's pretty but then it's got this stuff
oh that looks similar
how's this pizza man it's really good
[Music]
how's this pizza man it's good pizza
yeah
[Music]
the best in new york my opinion yeah
good [ __ ] box all right i'm in
i got it
what's the name of this place golden
pizza golden pizza right on
rocks what do you got to say about the
south frogs uh it's
quite a diverse loud place but there's
good people here
yeah try the pizza okay you like it is
this guy over here next to the car
regular everybody the regular here
people hang out here all the time solid
messy and good that's awesome
[Music]
golden pizza 138th street
and brook ave
highly recommend going here if you're in
new york cool guy that owns it too
[Music]
this guy is rocking the fashion what's
your name
good job juju dude you need to give me
some tips
bro i'm trying you know what i'm saying
i just i just uh
try to try to combine my colors real
well that's it
[Music]
that about wraps it up in the south
bronx but i want to
leave you with a few of the lessons i
learned a lot of drugs a lot of crime
there's some edge but i also want to
mention that there's a lot of beauty
here
there's a lot of human connection there
are a lot of smiles
a lot of people went out of their way to
help talk on camera
and yeah it's in this extreme place for
sure
but it's got something really cool in it
and the food is excellent
also if you want to support this channel
you can go to my patreon page i'll have
a link around here
i have different offerings you can dm me
and i will answer you
you can get the behind-the-scenes
footage you can make suggestions for
future videos
or you can just support the channel
whatever you'd like to do but that is
helping me
make this content so thanks for coming
along until the next one
from the south bronx
you